what a night last night. Um, I don't even
know really where to start. Uh, sir, we're
going to talk about the drama we were involved
in with CNN because of last night's debate,
but before I get to that, let's just talk
about the debate itself. Um, I am going to
say things that might shock you about Marianne
Williamson's performance last night, given
what I said about her a couple of weeks ago.
But before we get to that, we were wondering
in terms of the debate in general night one,
debate two last night, would Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren together be bad for the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party or
would it be good? My thought was that it would
be good and indeed it was very, very, very
good. Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
last night, completely dominated the first
night of this second presidential debate.
They did a stunningly good job of making it
clear that they are not the radicals, their
ideas are not the ideas outside of the main
stream. And that opposing their ideas is increasingly
what's radical, which was exactly my hope.
My idea was when I had had a video, a m answer,
I did a audience question, uh, about this
last week. My idea was that having both of
them up on the stage together rather than
each as the lone sort of strong progressive
on two different stages, that having them
together would create the idea that there
is this very strong, well thought out, uh,
of a mature contingent of the Democratic primary
that is adults in the room with serious, well
thought out ways to accomplish the more progressive
ideas that have been mainstreamed over the
last couple of years, which includes health
care, uh, inequality taxation, the military,
uh, tuition free college or tech college paid
for through a taxation. And both of them on
the stage together did exactly that. Warren
and Bernie had number one, a strong coalition
of the progressive part of the Democratic
Party. And number two, they had a bunch of
what I call debate kill shots.
And I hate that this is how debates are evaluated,
but both of them had good ones. The format
of these debates sadly doesn't allow for depth
because there's too many candidates. The answers
are too short and the topics are too wide
in one evening to really go in depth. There
should be, the ideal thing would be five candidates
for an hour and a half just on economics.
Five candidates for an hour and a half just
on foreign policy. It's not what we had. So
you've got to look at who had these kill shots
and both Bernie and Warren came prepared and,
uh, their biggest victory was making the point
that their ideas should be the norm, not the
exception. Let's look at a few of these moments.
One such moment was when, uh, John Delaney
started playing the role of the enlightened
pragmatist who isn't going to fall for the
unrealistic ideas of Elizabeth Warren or Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren shut it down.
Take a look.
So I think Democrats win when we run on real
solutions, not impossible promises when we
run on things that are workable, not fairy
tale economics. You know, I don't understand
why anybody does to all the trouble of running
for president of the United States just to
talk about what we really can't do and shouldn't
fight for.
[inaudible]
another instance, Bernie Sanders, straight
up telling Jake tapper, your question is a
right wing talking point, which sadly was
too common last night. I'm going to delve
more into that. This was just a very good
move by Bernie Jake tapper, asking candidates
if they're in favor of increasing taxes on
the middle class to pay for Medicare for all.
And Bernie said, Jake, that's a Republican
talking point. And by the way, for profit
healthcare companies are advertising on CNN
right now.
Jake, your question is a Republican talking
point at the end of the day, right?
By the way, and by the way, by the way,
the health care industry, we'll be advertising
to night on this program. You Senator, Senator
Warren, it's your turn. Yeah.
Oh good. I believe that place and your time
was I did I? Where's that talking point?
Senator Warren.
Elizabeth Warren said in no uncertain terms
that white supremacy has to be called domestic
terrorism. Yes, this is fantastic. I've been
saying this for years and it should be called
domestic terrorism and there were a lot of
zeroes and ones on yesterday's debate stage
who were desperate because they know this
is their last shot to make it into the third
debate. In early September, in the middle
of September, they need at least 2% in four
different polls plus 130,000 total donors
with no fewer than 400 donors from each of
20 states. So a lot of these zeros and ones
went in thinking, I'm just going to pick a
fight with anybody I can pick a fight with
Delaney with Warren was one example. Here's
Tim Ryan trying to get one over on Bernie
Sanders on medicare for all, and Bernie doesn't
have a second of it. He shuts it right down.
No sentence. They will be better because Medicare
for all is comprehensive. It covers all healthcare
needs for senior citizens. It will finally
include dental cap, hearing aids and eyeglasses,
but you don't second level, you don't have
a second of all comes in a second. When I
wrote the day of Bill
[inaudible],
boom. Bernie. Also, by the way, like Warren
calling out the people who say, we can't do
all of this stuff. Take a look at that.
I got a little bit tired up Democrats,
afraid of big ideas. Republicans are not afraid
of big ideas. They could give $1 trillion
in tax breaks to billionaires and profitable
corporations. They could bell out the quotes
on Wall Street, so please don't tell me that
we cannot take on the fossil fuel industry
and not going to happen unless we do that.
The
theme here was Number One, Bernie plus Warren
clearly developing the soil, sort of elder
statesman, progressive wing status within
this Democratic primary. That's a really good
thing. Showing the strength of the progressive
movement and of progressive ideas, making
those who oppose their ideas look, quite frankly,
very uninformed and very ignorant. Another
theme was Hadley, terrible moderation. Bernie
called out that one question. As a Republican
talking point, there were actually many of
these questions when they were talking about
paying for college through taxes. Some candidates
want to pay for two years, a associates degree.
Like I think better or Rourke, some candidates
want to do four years, but tuition only aware
as other candidates have the idea of more
comprehensive room and board and books and
fees even, which are quite high being covered
through taxation, but invariably this thing
comes up about if there's free college for
everyone, you're also paying for free college
for rich kids who we don't need to be paying
for.
Some of the dems sort of agreed with that.
Actually. I think Amy Klobuchar going from
memory didn't immediately shut down that concern
as she should have. This is a silly distraction
and it's the fault of the moderators and to
some degree the Democratic candidates could
have done a better job of exposing the question
is problematic. This was in yesterday. I did
my 2020 anti playbook for Democrats. What
not to do if you're trying to defeat Donald
Trump, don't get involved in losing debates.
Every social welfare program has some free
riders, either people who don't really need
the benefit but are getting it anyway and
or people who are lying in order to get a
benefit they shouldn't actually qualify for.
In this particular case with quote Free College,
but what we really mean is college paid for
through tax revenues that are connected. The
very rich kids are likely not even interested
in going to the state schools.
That would be tuition free. Under these plans
we're talking about a tiny fraction of the
money. That's such a plan would cost. We don't
need to worry about it. That's just the reality.
Harvard and Yale aren't covered by these plans.
We're talking about state, public colleges
and universities. It is a distraction from
the huge stimulative effect and huge value
that would come from people not coming out
of college and crazy student loan debt. If
you come out of college and crazy student
loan debt, you are paying interest two banksters
that's not economically stimulative. If you
come out of college without student loan debt,
yes, college may have been paid for partially
or fully through taxation. You are immediately
taking your wages and contributing them back
into the economy, not to banksters but to
local businesses and in ways that are actually
economically stimulative instead of interest
paid to big banks.
So that was just again the the framing of
the debate completely wrong. Now I also have
to drastically change my view about Marianne
Williamson and I know that some people are
worried about that because they're like, no,
no, no. Your view last week was the right
one. Marianne Williamson is very quirky. She
has no shot. She has the background as a new
age guru, which I am not a fan of, but she
actually did really well last night because
she stayed away mostly from her woo new age
stuff and Bernie and Warren definitely won
the debate. We could argue about who did better
than the other could go either way, but Marianne
Williamson's performance was clearly the third
place performance. Here she is whackamole
Lee talking about a dark psychic force, but
she actually sounds quite strong here and
gets a good reaction.
If you think any of this walking, this is
going to deal with this dark psychic force
of the collectivized cater that this president
is bringing up in this country, then I'm afraid
that the Democrats are going to see some very
dark days. We need to say it like it is. It's
bigger than Flint. It's all over this country.
It's particularly people of color. It particularly
people who do not have the money to fight
back and if they're Democrats don't start
saying it. And why would those people feel
that they're there for us?
And if those people don't feel that they won't
vote, listen,
she seems to always be on the edge of claiming
that we will solve our problems by holding
crystals. But she was actually quite strong
yesterday in her presentation. She's pulling
0.3% I don't know what it's going to do for
her, but she at least put in a good performance.
And there was this just general deficit of
a format that really allows deep conversation.
And in playing the game, Marianne Williamson
did well for herself. That being said, she's
wacky and people get mad at me for saying
this. People ask me what I mean, check out
just one example. Okay? In one of her books
she says, sickness is not a sign of God's
judgment, but of our judgment on ourselves,
we get sick if we judge ourselves. And then
she later says in the same page that sickness
is merely an illusion that doesn't exist.
Her 2010 weight loss book recommends sage
cleansing your kitchen and praying yourself
thin and she wants tweeted, God is big.
Swine flu, small. See every cell of your body
filled with divine light. Pour God's love
on our immune systems. Truth protect. This
is insanity. It's insanity. But she's funny
in the debates and I liked her presence and
the crowd was reacting positively to her.
Um, and she was clearly in third place and
I guess I would say booted, judge, sort of
able to tread water and do okay in some spots.
I would say putatively in fourth place, although
I don't know how much it will do with him.
10 a for him. Tonight we have Biden with a
bunch of other people. I will be streaming
live commentary on twitch at twitch.tv/david
Pacman. I hope you will follow me there. And
next I want to talk about why I will be streaming
on twitch.